cuando Simón se presentó ante el
parlamento en 1974 para pedir la
legalización del aborto se produjo una
acalorado debate uno similar al que la
asamblea nacional de Francia acogerá de
nuevo este jueves para votar si se
incluye el derecho al aborto en la
Constitución los diputados examinarán un
proyecto de ley presentado por el
partido de izquierda Francia insumisa en
un raro intento de bipartidismo el texto
parece contar con el apoyo del partido
renacimiento del presidente macon el
mayor es del parlamento cuyos diputados
podrían votar a favor del proyecto pero
el debate podría complicarse ya que el
texto tiene más de 250 enmiendas la
mayoría añadidas por el partido
conservador los republicanos el partido
de extrema derecha agrupación nacional
que se oponen a Añadir el aborto a la
Constitución las mujeres francesas
tienen derecho al aborto desde que se
aprobó la ley de Simón baile en 1975 Así
que algunos se preguntarán a Por qué los
políticos quieren incluirlo ahora en la
constitución
según el portavoz del gobierno Olivia y
vegao el impulso comenzó después de que
el tribunal supremo de Estados Unidos
derogar a el fire Road versus wade
Estados Unidos no se ha demostrado que
el derecho al aborto es frágil y puede
ser cuestionado muy rápidamente debemos
protegerlo al consagrar el derecho al
aborto en nuestra Constitución hoy
haremos aún más difícil suprimirlo
mañana
algunos políticos dicen que también es
una reacción a otros países europeos en
los que se ha restringido el acceso al
aborto como Polonia o Hungría pero
constitucionalizar el derecho al aborto
no será fácil y llevaría tiempo el mes
pasado el senado dominado por la derecha
rechazó una propuesta similar con 139
votos a favor y 172 en contra ambas
cámaras del parlamento deben redactar y
aprobar cuidadosamente el proyecto de
ley para evitar que se someta a refer